hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in part four of his discourse on method
Descartes is going to use the terms
Being and Nothingness in a ways that I
think may trip up many contemporary
readers who aren't quite getting what
he's attempting to say and which was
perfectly clear in his own time but but
maybe less clear for those of us in the
present who aren't used to thinking in
these these ways so it's worth dwelling
on precisely what role Being and
Nothingness have in decart's arguments
and explanations and and how these
actually work for him and it will help
us to think about the nature of the
human being and our mind and our ideas
as well so let's start with some general
associations so Dickert talks about
truth which is what he's seeking in the
discourse and he's focused on knowledge
and knowledge and truth or in certain
ways correlative terms right knowledge
is of the true and we can say that
knowledge is a true relation between the
mind and and other things an idea can be
true for Descartes connections of ideas
can be true we even have an idea of
truth implanted within us as he says at
another point he also uses the language
of participation and this may throw us a
bit because we might be thinking of it
in a very platonic way in terms of the
you know the forms and and Descartes
doesn't have something like that in mind
but he does think that there is a way in
which we you might say take on something
from what it is that we're participating
in and what is it that true things or
knowledge participates in being the most
broad thing that you can say existence
so let's take something fairly simple
you know and assume that this is
actually correct and I'm not
photoshopping things right the chalk is
in my hand
and a true proposition it now at
proposition within your mind there is a
being hero as a matter of fact a number
of beings all related to each other in
certain ways and they have being and as
your understanding that the ideas that
you have are participating in being just
as much as this truck is or I you know
communicating to you are now it gets a
bit trickier when we get to the opposite
right
what about falsity what about when
things are not at the way that we claim
that they are or the way that we think
that they are if I say the chalk is in
my hand and you see there is no chalk
there and I say oh no no I insist it's
there you just can't see it now I'm
deceiving you and if you believe me you
are in fact deceived the way Descartes
talks about this which I think may be a
little bit tricky we have to wrap our
heads around this is that when something
like that is occurring there is a
participation no longer in being but in
nothingness the French term for that
remember the discourse is written in
French originally Nant nothingness
non-being we could translate it as
nothing if you want although usually
area would be translated as nothing it
means a lack or a privation or simply
the absence of being so falsity in a
certain respect is a lack of being not a
total lack of being because if there was
absolutely nothing there there couldn't
be anything false if there wasn't a hand
to say the chalk is right here there's a
being here but there's a being that's
missing the truck you registering it as
a false proposition means that in a way
you're participating in being and you're
also participating in non being in a
weird sort of way so if you if the court
doesn't really dwell on this that much
but if you think this through I think
that will
help you to understand what he's
actually saying in part four of the
discourse on metaphysics on method so
let's go on a little bit further he's
talking about what goes on when we get
things wrong so our our ideas that are
false
remember the for Descartes what is the
criterion of ideas that are actually
true clarity and distinctness the idea
is in fact clear and it is distinct from
other ideas that it might resemble in
some way now
we're often wrong about that we think
that things are clearer and more
distinct than they really are
and so we get we get mixed up and we
mistake the false for the true when we
do that our ideas are actually the
opposite they are to some degree
confused that's the opposite of clear
clear ideas you could say show
themselves to be such confused ideas are
kind of a mess right think about when
you try to explain your emotions to
somebody those are generally rather
unclear ideas right or confused ideas
and obscure right actually confuse the
opposite of distinct obscure right in
any case we might mix ideas up with
others we can't tell them apart and
there can be sort of like a you know
bottom level these things are not clear
and distinct and then a higher level we
think that they actually are so there
can be participation in falseness or in
nothingness that's going on in two ways
again a little bit more complicated than
what Descartes is talking about here but
that's part of the background
metaphysics by doing that that's when he
says that they actually participate in
nothingness or non-being so things being
ambiguous things being unclarified
things getting substituted for each
other without us actually realizing it
as for example when we transfer some sum
some properties that belong over here to
something over here by the use of our
imagination we're participating to a
certain degree in nothingness by doing
so and again I realize that this is a
rather strange way of talking for some
but this is a metaphysics that that
makes sense within dick Hart's work now
here's the really interesting question
that we can ask ourselves so far we've
been talking about our ideas which are
things you know we can say they're in
our head they're not really in our head
there in our mind all right and we've
been talking about things out there in
the world or perhaps the the ideas that
we have of them or you know ideas like
that of God and the being that God would
be and so on and so forth what is our
own nature or a metaphysical status
Descartes tells us that it is imperfect
we are not God that's why we doubt
that's why we lack knowledge that's why
we get deceived that's why we believe
false things to be true sometimes and
true things to be false sometimes and
sometimes can't even tell true and false
apart from each other so we're imperfect
what does that mean about our own
metaphysical status that means that we
are poised in between full being and
nothingness now I'm representing this
with my my hands in a sort of spacial
way there is no continuum in that sense
right it's not like there's a scale
where being is on one side and
nothingness is on the other because
nothing this isn't anywhere there is no
nothingness strictly speaking and yet we
do participate in it this may in fact
sound to many of you like reflections
coming from Heidegger or Sartre Sartre
has an entire book called Being and
Nothingness but these are reflections
that are already there
Rene Descartes and the discourse on
method there underlying the background
so what is our goal that our goal by
perfecting our minds is to perfect our
very being to participate more fully in
being and participate less in
nothingness by getting our ideas clear
and distinct and rejecting ideas that
that are not such as being false or
being beyond the pale we in effect strip
nothingness away from us or if you like
we we remove ourselves from the
nothingness and closer to the perfection
of full being this goes a little bit
beyond what Descartes is saying here in
the discourse but I hope that you find
this useful for understanding des cartes
references to not just truth and falsity
but to participation in being and
participation in nothingness
you